JANA MOUDRA: Hi.
My name is Jana Moudra, and
I'm a co-founder of Juicymo.
I love to talk about technology.
So this is the reason why I'm
a Google Developer Expert.
I grew up on the web.
At first, I started with design.
And then I just started coding.
It was difficult to me at first
but then I started to love it.
And now it's my dream job.
Later, I explored Android,
the green little robot.
And I decided to explore
it because I wanted
to create a mobile app, which
I can share with the world
and show it to my friends.
So I started, and you can
imagine how I enjoy that.
Nothing is impossible in
this world, believe me.
I really wanted to start using
my [INAUDIBLE] language called
Dart with a service
called Firebase.
There was no library to do so.
So I implemented it.
And a couple of months later,
Google merged my repository
into their own.
So my library became official.
And then I could
share how to build
great apps with
Dart and Firebase
under official Dart conference.
And that's very motivating.
I get a lot of very
interesting opportunities.
I could organize even the GDC.
Or as a member of Google
Developer Expert program,
I could meet lots of
very inspiring developers
all around the world,
and create new friends.
I love how tech is not
just about programming.
You can do beautiful designs
or marketing for your product.
And if you think
that you as a woman
will have difficulty
in tech then Google
thinks of you with the program
called Women Techmaker.
Becoming a part of the tech
community is really easy.
It was one of the best
things I've ever made.